do you think that someone who's had high
expectations placed on them by family or
a peer group actually suffers creatively
more than possibly a kid from a poor
background that's had no expectations
placed on them and they're free to do
whatever they want i can give you a more
generic answer to that by telling you
about a classic psychological experiment
oh she likes psychology hey guy this is
a fella named Murray very big
psychologists in the 50s this is a
classic study at Harvard took a bunch of
kids gave him a battery of personality
tests that determine whether they were
secure or insecure then they gave them
some darts and said throw the darts at
this target and you could stand very
close a moderate distance away or very
far and you wagered and the amount of
money you won was commensurate with the
distance so if you were very close he
wouldn't win much money because it was
so easy you know very far away you went
a lot of money because it was so hard
now this gets turned around to you where
do you think the secure and the insecure
people chose to stay what are their
comfort zones give me specifics where
did the secure people stand probably
farther from the target and the insecure
people closer soon okay totally wrong
usually people don't get this totally
wrong you get the distinction the secure
people stood in the middle where they
took a moderate risk for a moderate
reward the insecure people were bimodal
II split half stood very close we
understand that now somebody will work
at an insurance company for twenty three
hundred dollars a month they're never
going to hit a home run but this can be
food on the table but why would insecure
people stand very very far away risk the
possibility that it could pay off look
at the flip side if it doesn't they've
cushioned their fall if you take a
longer at risk and you fail you're just
not very good
but if your way out here well yeah I
didn't sell the screenplay but hey you
know I'm out there trying and it's hard
to sell screenplay you cushion your fall
so it's there's something very safe
about taking a very great risk with your
life sting because you're not a failure
if you miss in the same way that if you
take a moderate-sized a realistic risk
oh yeah that's interesting I also would
add a corollary to this and that is that
what I've noticed you're gonna dispute
henri marie no i'm going to talk about
something that comes off that about you
know screw with marie about what is
success what is failure and maybe this
just comes from now like I've only been
he's been teaching for a long time i've
only been teaching like 11 years but you
know I wonder if you know just you know
there's a lot of very successful people
who are miserable human beings does that
make them successful you know so they've
had success they've taken aureus they're
not happy people but I'm am I feeling
about successes are you doing something
maybe have to be a little older to sort
of feel this but are you doing something
that you get up in the morning and look
forward to doing and and and are you
contributing something because I think
we're living in a time hopefully will
come out of it soon i think maybe some
recent events will hopefully start to
change this but this is me thing about
its Mike I we had this house guest I
give me this is a perfect example and it
was twelve twelve twelve and my wife and
my daughter and this house guest from
Australia she they were all wishing cuz
and it was right after the horrible
thing that happened and kinetic or right
before no I guess it was what I forget
what date that was but and this girl
said well I hope I win an Oscar this
year and I and I'm thinking to myself
that's a very young person's wish that
isn't that is a very self-centered view
of life
and that is a view of success you could
get that Oscar and never work again that
happened to James the great James
culprit couldn't get roles after his
ostrich know how long his career was and
yes struggle I think he did work but so
I just wonder I haven't come to a
conclusion about it but what I do tell
my students is making a lot of money
isn't necessarily gonna make you happy
seen a lot of people who make a lot of
money on her miserable human beings and
don't help other people look at Matt
Damon look what a great guy Matt Damon
is I was just watching a thing on him
this morning he's taking his life which
has been blessed and he's passing it on
George Clooney another great guy right
Sandra Bullock these are great people
and they know how bless their that's the
thing is I think you can't know in your
20s you can't know how blessed you are
because you don't see it cuz all you see
is what's ahead of you to what you
haven't done well who's getting right I
faster than you something yeah I think
once you hit your mid-30s it becomes
less about that and what's gonna make me
have what's gonna make me want to get up
in the morning I mean what you guys are
doing i think is and i have nothing i
need from you except an interview at
some point but i mean i think that you
know you out you seem like fulfilled
people you don't seem like you're I
don't know I know a lot of people in
their 40s who are unhappy you know yeah
I think we're and maybe we'll edit some
of this out and where this is my
questions going is you know I've known a
lot of very wealthy kids from very
wealthy homes and I grew up very poor
and I saw that there was a great
expectation placed on them that's funny
and I think that they were held back
creatively in some sense because they
were maybe not in Hollywood I mean the
rich kids were held back a little bit
because maybe that they read the parents
really wanted
to go to great places great schools that
become the pharmacist and do these
different things and again maybe not
Holly what if you call it as a different
animal where is what the poor kids and
you're lucky he's going to get a job and
also they had a no creative freedom and
some of them became musicians or
different things and they actually made
a sustainable living off of it well III
corporal a lot of wealthy people not
show business wealthy right right and I
think that could be a burden to I mean
suppose you have a trust fund sure and
you know you don't have to work that be
I mean my I mean I think you know I come
back to Steven Spielberg I think if
Steven Spielberg had been born with a 5
trillion dollars he still would have
done what he's done because it's his
need to make movies he's had that since
he was a little boy but I i I've been
close to people whose lives were ruined
by having money you know back I was
talking to an accountant the county's
come up all right um-hmm was telling me
that right around the time of the toward
the end of the dot-com boom back in the
90s that he had a bunch of clients who
were average middle-aged couples who all
of a sudden were part of this company
now they have 38 million dollars and two
kids and said how am I gonna get my kid
to want to study how gibran high school
when he knows he's going to get 14
million dollars in the trust fund back
worker and they worked out all these
weird incentives for their kids you know
well if you get this kind of grade point
average you get this if you graduate
from this school you get this sitting at
this guy literally they were trying to
build incentives in because they felt
you'll be crippling to know that no
matter what you do you're covered see I
grew up having absolutely no
expectations from my parents my dad was
out here I was raised by my pretty much
by my stepfather and my mother who had
issues mental health issues and you
could edit this out of you want to I'm
sure
boring as hell but the part that's
interesting is I think sometimes rich
kids or kids who have you know who are
ok financially can't and their parents
don't or their grandparents or whomever
they don't have any expectations either
yeah I don't think there were rules no
no I mean again it's like every every
case is individual I can tell you with
people having sat in that chair that all
different backgrounds there's no no
walls and Karen's chair or my care
you